hanck after a long delay because of snow
in Columbus Ohio I finally reached
Houston Texas where by the grace of God
it is not snowing there was one really
cool thing about the Columbus Airport
though they had nerdfighters
nerdfighters here's my question about
nerdfighters his nerdfighters a game
about people who fight against nerds or
is it a game about nerds who fight
against other people I've come to
believe that nerdfighters is a game
about nerds who fight nerds who tackle
the scourge of popular people and I've
been thinking to myself this would be a
great video game it could be like a mix
between Mortal Kombat and Mike Tyson's
punch-out like first you pick your
character everyone would totally have
their own special powers like the band
geek would be like I will destroy your
ears with my tuba and the theater guy
would be like I am an expert at sword
fighting and the English nerd would be
like um I know a lot of Shakespeare
quotes using the English nerd when
you're playing nerd fighters is kind of
like using toad when you're playing
Super Mario Kart so you would pick your
nerd fighter and then you would go to
war with popular people the Mike Tyson
of the game would be the quarterback of
the high school football team and you'd
have to dodge his uppercuts and dodge
his uppercuts and dodges uppercuts and
then jab I mean to be honest I've never
even really understood the war between
nerds and popular people like
hooty-hooty-hoo do you guys got
we got like george w bush and like Tom
Brady ok well I see your George W Bush
with Bill Clinton and I raise you a
neighbor ahem Lincoln and a Franklin
Delano Roosevelt and I can easily see
your Tom Brady with the thinking man's
football player Tiki Barber and I think
I can raise you hmm an Isaac Newton of
William Shakespeare Blaise Pascal and
Albert Einstein and Immanuel Kant in
Aristotle a Jane Austen and Bill Gates
and Mahatma Gandhi and Nelson Mandela
and all four Beatles we win and yet Hank
the war continues you know we need four
nerdfighters we need a theme song
we've got calculators and trombones
we've got DN DN Star Wars drones they're
in the original box too which makes them
a lot more valuable nerdfighters the
fighting nerds we're no longer just
using our words although by Narns we are
really articulate so when I'm not
watching Battlestar Galactica on
designing weapons that'll kick your ass
touka nerdfighters we fight with our
brains nerdfighters we bring the frakkin
pain it's a reference to a sci-fi show I
don't know I mean maybe you never saw
those really it was a really good show I
liked it a lot and some of my friends
liked it I mean not they're not real
friends I just know them on on the
Internet
Hank now that you successfully completed
the Strawberry Hill challenge I feel
like it's time that we had some more
challenges so maybe you or our viewers
can start suggesting some